Who is
the god like Yahweh the god
of wrath the god of Mercy The
God Who reaches down to unworthy people.
Well Merry Christmas church.
So you're like did I miss something here? I know went
to bed early that I hibernate for two months. No. Okay. Listen, I
know it's cooler outside and maybe I'm
just really Desiring Christmas season, but you are
not crazy. We are still walking through
this journey through Micah in the
Old Testament where we are seeing God's fullness. But
but today we get to come to
a passage that's pretty familiar predicting this
Messiah who is coming.
And it's one that we often use at Christmas because it talks about this little town
called Bethlehem.
And so to celebrate I brought this little Christmas tree up here
that I keep in my study over in the offices and just keep
it up there all year round. I don't know where Emily and I obtained this
but somehow it came
to our house and it sure came in handy when we were
in Fort Worth a few years ago.
See if you didn't know my wife and I both have engineering degrees
from Oklahoma State University and we went
to Seminary. I went to Seminary in Fort
Worth. And so while I was in summary actually worked for two years
designing HVAC systems in buildings using my
degree which eight to five traveling for
work battling traffic the whole deal like working
with unbelievers all that. I experience that and
by the way, I'm so thankful for that because it gave me a picture of what
real real Ministry in the world looks like like
when you go to work during the week, I understand what
that is. So God blessed me with that opportunity, but I
started working at that company right before Christmas.
And so I brought this little Christmas tree to my cubicle and I
put it right up on top the top highest shelf
in my cubicle where we're really everybody could see as
they walk by could see it from a kind of across the room and those kind
of things and other people had Decor up and stuff like that. So I
wasn't the only one
the difference was I just left this up all year.
Now I probably just forgot to take it home in January. But but
it really worked out providentially for me in a
number of different ways because people would walk by like in
February or June and they'd
be like, you know Christmas was a
couple months ago, right?
And and I would have the opportunity.
This this question provided an opportunity for me to actually
get to the gospel.
Because my response to them would be Hey, listen
for me every day is Christmas Day.
Now they'd go report me to HR. But anyway, it was
like this thing of like I don't think he's saying but it was the
idea that I would tell them.
This reality that it's not just a holiday to celebrate once
a year for us who are believers.
That this is something that signifies.
That our Savior King has come and that
changes everything.
Like this is reality. Something has happened that if God
really did take on human flesh to come
save us then that deserves a year-round celebration,
right? That's not just a little few week
few days in a week at the end of
the year.
In fact, that's the main point. We're going to see today actually.
In Micah 5. We'll see that that every day is Christmas
Day.
so rejoice
every day is Christmas Day.
So Rejoice take heart.
Take joy.
Because the Messiah has come.
That changes everything.
And so let's turn now to Micah chapter 5.
Micah chapter 5 is where we're going to be today. I'm
going to call a little bit of an audible today. We had
planned Micah five two through
nine for today and some of you may have even studied
that this morning or will in your community groups. We are
still going to cover that but I realize as
I Was preparing that I bit off a little bit too much to chew in
those eight verses and so what we're
gonna do is shift.
The second part of verse 5 all the way down through verse 9 on
to next week and it'll be with verses 10
through 15. It's actually going to fit well together in that as well.
But today we're just going to focus in on
verses 2 through the first line of verse 5.
Very familiar passage, but here's what I believe God
wanted to do with this.
Sovereign right so he knew this was coming he new how this would work
out this week. And so what he wants to do, I believe as I
was seeing him do that in me this week as I Was
preparing it these few verses
Will lead us to just stare at
Jesus for the next 30 or 40 minutes.
Like to just gaze at his glory
because that's what we're gonna see in this passage. I'm going to get Christmas in October
Christmas and Micah
It's just going to tell us about the Messiah.
Just who he is who he was who he's going to
be like this. This should not be a lot of application today
right now. I can get this thing to walk out here. This is what I should do
today this week. No, that's not gonna be that. It's just gonna look at Jesus.
Going to lead us to respond in worship with
our whole lives more fully.
Which I'm fine with if you're fine with rest sound good, right? Like let's just
look at Jesus for the next 30 minutes.
So see if this passage. I read it see if
it sounds Christmassy to you.
Because all through Micah we've seen we've been
looking for this deliver looking for this king that's coming.
Listen to what? This says versus two through
the first line of verse 5.
Says but you o Bethlehem.
Ephratha you who are too little to be among the clans of
Judah from you shall come forth for me
one who is to be ruler in Israel.
Who's coming forth is from of old from ancient days?
Therefore he shall give them up until the time when she who
is in labor has given birth.
Then the rest of his brothers shall return to the people of Israel.
And he this this ruler shall
stand and Shepherd his flock in the strength of
the Lord in the Majesty of the name of the Lord his God.
And they shall dwell secure.
For now, he shall be great to the ends of
the Earth.
Shall be their peace.
God we look at this and we see Christmas. Yes, but but
may we see you today?
Now pray you would open our eyes.
Open our hearts.
To just be stirred and worship with our
whole lives.
Because you've come.
This is who you are. May we see that in fresh ways today?
understand you better than ever before see how
this all links together and
and glorify you with our lives. Help us God.
In jesus' name we pray.
amen
and so again, what we're going to do is we're just going to gaze at this
Messiah deliver that we've been waiting for in Micah
that they were waiting for that we see here in these few
verses
just look at this Messiah who he
is and that should land lead us to Faith should lead
us to worship. Let's just study him.
So what do we see here about him?
Well first just some some basic factual information
about him is that this Messiah would be
born in Bethlehem?
Right just a basic Truth born in Bethlehem. In
fact, most people if they've been around any form of
church their entire lives at all. They've they've probably
got this one in the bank somewhere right Bethlehem is
where he was going to be born. Right? They they have heard that
somewhere or sung the song but what you might not know
is there actually two bethlehems in that
region.
Which is why this one is distinguished as Bethlehem Ephrata?
And what that word does is it links it
with David?
It links to with David's Hometown. So how how does that that's
King David David Goliath, right? How does it link that with David?
Well in 1st Samuel 17:12 we
read this.
That David was the son of an ephrathite of
Bethlehem in Judah named
Jesse.
So David was from this town.
It's important. This actually also shows up later. When
when Joseph who was Mary's husband. This
was 2,000 years ago now.
Joseph Mary's husband. Jesus is adopted father.
He took Mary with him whenever the census
was called for he took him back where
He took them back to Bethlehem, which is
where Joseph's family was from.
He was an ephrathite.
And then we linked this with the Isaiah 11:1 it
predicts there shall come forth a shoot from the stump of
Jesse.
A branch from his roots shall bear fruit. So you
tie all of these pieces together and what you get
is this fulfillment of the prophecy from Micah?
700 years before Jesus was born that
the Messiah he's predicting was going
to be born in this little town of Bethlehem.
That the Savior was coming through the line of Jesse in the
line of David the line of Judah really from before in Genesis 49
that this was all going to happen in this Tiny Town
of Bethlehem.
Micah said 700 years before it happened. Here's how
it goes.
So this Messiah deliver born in Bethlehem?
But not just a person born somewhere
the second aspect of this Messiah deliver is that
he would be living for Yahweh.
It says very clearly this Messiah is going to
live for Yahweh in verse 2. God says out of
this Tiny Town one shall come forth for
me. Those two words for me is what we're focused
on.
Now I feel like an insignificant part of this verse it's
not that big of a deal here. Actually it is
because remember
how the vast majority of all the other
rulers in Israel and Judah had been
How had they been living?
They were Wicked idolatrous leaders.
Leading their people into their own sin.
Into idolatry into worshiping of the Gods this was who
they had been all of them had fallen short of
God's standard of what a king was supposed to be.
this King, however
The Messiah King would be for Yahweh.
Would come forth for me. God says for Yahweh
both in orientation the way that he's focused
on his life that he would be solely focused on pleasing
the father. He's four Yahweh, but
also
as a perfect representative of Yahweh.
He's for me.
Right. This is who I want you to see as a
representative of me. It's what Colossians 1
says about Jesus.
That he is the image of
the invisible God.
perfect picture
of God In the Flesh
And in him all the fullness of God was pleased to
dwell. That's who Jesus is said
to be that that he is for God.
Given for us that means everything about the
Messiah would perfectly point to Yahweh.
All these failed Kings along the way even David failed Kings
would not perfectly represent.
until the Messiah
it's what it Isaiah 11.
prophesied about this
one to come says the spirit of the Lord shall rest
upon him.
The spirit of wisdom and understanding the spirit of counsel and
might the spirit of knowledge and the fear of the Lord.
And his Delight shall be in the fear of the
Lord. He shall not judge by what his eyes see or
decide disputes by what his ears hear but with righteousness he
shall judge the poor.
And decide with equity for the meek of the Earth.
He shall strike the Earth with the rod of his mouth with
the breath of his lips. He shall kill the wicked.
And righteousness shall be the belt of his waist and faithfulness
the belt of his loins.
When you look through that list of what that Messiah is going to be. It sounds
like what Israel and Judah were missing out on right?
The way they were treating the poor the way they were treating the wicked,
right? They get preference to the evil preference to the wealthy.
All of that was happening. No the Messiah.
Will be living for Yahweh. And this is what it
will look like.
totally different
now
it could be that that person is different and just one
of many.
But it's really important that this Messiah would be
a ruler in Israel.
Notice, that's what it says in Micah 5 that that this one
who's going to be living for Yahweh is actually going to
be the ruler in Israel. He would take the rightful place.
That God was supposed to have as the king.
God had ordained that they were there these
kings that they wanted were supposed to be some certain
way. They've kept failing at that because
they were supposed to be a theocracy originally.
That word being means that they were supposed to be having God
as their King solely as a nation
that God was the king over them. They rebelled against
that they wanted an Earthly King instead. And God
said, okay, here you go, but they kept getting in trouble because of all
these Wicked kings that they had.
And God said, well, actually I wanted you to follow me.
I wanted you to follow me not these
people who will lead you astray who will fail you at times
follow me. Let me be your king. And so
now with the Messiah we get back to that.
We get back to this being the true king the Everlasting King.
The one who is not just a ruler in
Israel the one who is the ruler of Israel?
Totally different right the sure final
King that they actually need. He's the one who's going to
fill that void.
He's the one that God promised to David.
Back in second Samuel 7:16 when he's
talking to David about this family line that he has. He
says your house and your kingdom.
Shall be made sure forever before me.
Your throne David shall be established forever.
He's pointing forward to this Messiah King. Who's from
the line of David remember?
Through Jesse through Bethlehem this
one who's going to come?
Will be sure and established Forever This
is Jesus the one that they called son of David.
This is Jesus who fulfills this a ruler
they need?
But when you think about it, he says here your throne
will be established forever. How can someone Reign forever?
The only way someone can Reign forever is if they have existed from
eternity as well.
Like this is this is an eternal ruler. This is somebody who's
existed forever and ever both eternity
past and Eternity future. That's the word in verse
2. It says this Messiah is coming forth is
from of old.
from ancient days
That language is the same language used in Daniel chapter
7.
Talking about God and it says he is the Ancient of
Days.
same idea
and what that means is that God is eternal.
It's showing God's eternality which God himself
says about the Messiah here that he has existed from
those ancient days.
This is a key theological Point here that that we need
to keep in our minds. Remember. Jesus was not created 2,000
years ago in Mary's womb.
Like you and I are created when when those two
cells come together and it's a new creation. That's a whole
new thing. It's it's something that didn't exist before what Jesus
did as Eternal God the son.
He just took on flesh there in Mary's womb.
He doesn't have the seed of man.
like we do
he is God who's existed and just just take
on flesh.
So he's a hundred percent God and a hundred
percent man.
Living this life for us
and dying and resurrecting and ascending back like that's
that's God but it starts not at the
womb. It starts from eternity past.
I know that kind of blows our minds hard to conceive hard to get yes.
But what that means is that when you look at Jesus.
As the image of the invisible God you are looking at the
Eternal God.
You are looking at Eternal God who not
only existed eternity past. He's also existing into eternity
future.
So the one who's going to Reign on the
throne of David forever is someone who does exist
forever?
His name is Jesus.
But here's where things get a little tricky.
Not that that wasn't complicated enough, right? Okay.
but remember for those who were hearing this 2,700 years
ago as Micah was writing these and saying
these things
at the time this promised King that he's talking about was still
future for them, right?
I mean, they're literally in threats. They're at risk
for Exile and and at War and
So they're hoping forward future for this promised
Messiah this King.
It was all still future because if you've tracked with us through Micah here,
right you you remember there's a lot of pain and sorrow there
about to have to go through.
God was disciplining his people to purify and
refine out this Remnant and so now
They're going to have to go through some pain before this savior
would come that's what verse 3 refers to he says
this King will give them up until the
time comes.
He's talking about the exile.
He's talking about that. They're about to go to Babylon in the next hundred years
or so. They're going to go to Babylon for a season, but then sometime after
that.
A woman will give birth to this child.
And then the exiled Brothers will return.
And so here again, this is what we talked about a couple
weeks ago this already but not yet nature of the kingdom of
God.
And some of that makes it really confusing when we deal with prophecy and
how to handle where when this was going to happen. Did it
happen like this time and later or is it just once or is it future is
it current?
We hit it here because what he's talking about was fulfilled in
part.
A couple hundred years later when the remnant of God's
people return to the land from Babylon.
That's Ezra Nehemiah you go read those books. That's their Journey back
into the land that they were in
right now that they got exiled from.
so there's a partial fulfillment of them coming back
to the land but
Just a shadow.
Because there was not full.
full fulfillment of all that we see here in Micah 5
there was not this one Messiah King who would do all of
these things it wasn't true yet.
It was a partial fulfillment.
But it's a shadow of the full and complete return
coming one day for God's people.
That there had to be this this woman giving birth
to a child.
And then everybody comes back together.
Well, we have the ability, of course to look
back at something that happened for
us 2,000 years ago for them 700 years later.
Where this woman named Mary did birth a
child. Who is this deliverer Jesus?
Who fulfills all these prophecies? We now look
back and say that's the Messiah.
And so that's already happened in some sense, right? It
has but
but the full return has not yet happened.
We're still in kind of this Exile period in a
sense where we're not unified. We're not back in
the land. We're not with our Messiah King reigning
we're not there yet. All of these things in verses three
through five haven't happened yet.
And so they have in some sense. Yes, there's glimpses of
it, but we're still looking forward to a day to come right?
When this Messiah deliverer will come back fully and finally and
Reign on Earth as he is right now in heaven. We are
looking forward to that day as well. There's a there's a
future element to us here as well.
That we're longing for something just like they were
longing for something.
But here's what this passage also does.
See there's this Messiah deliver. We've been talking about there's this
Messiah King coming. What will he
do?
when his kingdom fully comes
What is he already doing in some sense? But what he will
do fully verse 4 says he will Shepherd in
strength.
Just abundantly clear. He will Shepherd in strength here.
And that image of of shepherdings all over Micah, right?
They would understood that they saw Shepherds all the time. They get that
idea. But what we learned from this is this
is a picture of security protection love.
When he Shepherds in strength, there's a Shepherd cares
for and protects his flock this Messiah will
do the same for his sheep for those who are
his by faith.
He will Shepherd his flock. That's
what the word stand brings here.
Because it says he'll stand and Shepherd his flock what
that word stand means is that he has the authority needed to
complete the task.
and that's good news because
he should be if we're trusting in Him
to do it. He should have the authority to do it and he also not only has that
he has the strength of Yahweh to do it as well.
He's got the authority to do it. He's got the strength to
do it. He can be our Shepherd. That means there's nothing that can stand
against him.
There's nothing that can separate his flock from his protective hand.
This is the messiah.
and the beauty of this
Is that Jesus gladly takes up
that mantle in the New Testament?
We're in John. 10:14. Jesus says I am the
Good Shepherd.
right this this shepherding and strength and Micah 2 says is
going to come the Micah 5 says is going to come Jesus says
I'm here.
I am this Good Shepherd and
just listen, I'm gonna read a lot of that passage in Luke in John
10. Listen to what that means when he says he's the Good Shepherd
listen.
It says he knows his own and his own
know him.
He calls his Sheep by name and he
leads them out.
That's you and me if we're his.
He goes before them and they follow his
voice.
He stays when it gets hard.
And he lays his life down to give
his sheep Abundant Life.
church that
Is what it means to Shepherd in strength.
When Jesus says I am the Good Shepherd.
He's looking back to this picture in Micah 5 of shepherding his
strength. Jesus says I am the Good Shepherd, but don't think
it's something different. Here's what it means. Jesus says.
I'm gonna lead you I'm gonna know you I'm going to guide you
and be with you. I'm going to protect you. I'm going
to
die for you
that is shepherding in strength. It's not arrogant. It's
not domineering.
It's humble sacrificial leadership.
That's what it means to Shepherd in Bible terms.
But here's what we can get to with that.
We can think that that means
it's soft.
It's weak.
Right that that means are you shepherding? You're just gonna sit around on rocks
and talk about Theology and have a good time together.
Right, that's not the only idea of shepherding.
It's not weak because Micah 5 verse 4.
Says the reason he can bring that security is because of
his great power.
Because he's great in power.
Listen to verse 4 again.
It says he shall stand and Shepherd his flock in the strength
of the Lord in the Majesty of the name the Lord
his God and they shall dwell secure for now.
He shall be great to the ends of the Earth.
Did you see the shepherding idea has with it
strength? We already saw that.
That means his foundation strong secure. His walls are
strong enough to hide in he has the strength needed
but then there's this idea. He's standing shepherding
in the Majesty of the Lord.
That word majesty means height or
imminence.
The idea is imagine a throne room
of a palace.
And the King's throne is elevated above everything else.
There's always steps up to it like every movie you watch every thing picture
you there's always steps up to the throne. It's always elevated
above everything else. Why?
Because it's signifies strength and power
and authority.
That you should not dare come against the person sitting
on that throne.
They have the full power to do anything they
want to do.
That's the idea here with this word majesty in
the Majesty's. He's shepherding in the Majesty The
Authority imminence power of
the Lord our God.
Not only that. There's this word great at the end of
verse 4.
It says the Messiah will be great to the ends of
the Earth that word great means. Yes, he's going to be famous. He's
gonna be glorious, of course, but the the idea
of the word great is that it brings
with it strength.
Think about that great mountain in chapter 4 that's
going to be elevated above all the other mountains. It's a great Mountain. It
doesn't mean it's just like awesome thumbs up. It's powerful.
And and the think about when the Magi from
the East came to see Jesus in chapter 4
it talked about the Nations will stream to this great
mountain, right?
This is a symbol of what's happening. Is that Jesus is
this one on the mountain who's raining
and the nations are beginning to stream to him.
Desire to hear who he is and what he says.
But he'll be great. It means strong and above
all the others and all of that fits together
to think about this Messiah that he is great in
power.
Nothing can stand against him. Nothing is stand
in opposition and last they can try but they will not
last our King will win the war in the end.
That's why we can dwell secure Church.
This is who our Messiah is we can dwell secure
that doesn't mean we won't go through hard times in this
life. And as we Face things now, but it
does mean we can trust him on the backside of this. There's
going to be glory.
That's what Psalm 144 verse 2 says that he
is my steadfast love and my Fortress.
my stronghold
my deliverer
my shield in whom I take refuge.
Is he that for you?
Do you run to him whenever things get
hard?
Or do you run to anything else?
Is he your Refuge?
He is powerful. So run and rest.
in him
But there's one more aspect of this Messiah that we need to see today.
It's the very first phrase of chapter of
verse 5.
And it's a simple phrase It's just says and he
shall be their peace.
He shall be.
their peace
this Messiah deliver
this Savior King that they were waiting for
that we get the picture of here. Not only will he
give his people peace. He is
their peace. He will be their peace.
Because think about what we've just seen about this Messiah.
He is King.
He has eternal power. He has strength he has Authority he
has Majesty. He has Greatness by virtue of
all of that. He is our peace.
In fact, that's how Isaiah frames it in Isaiah 9
verses 6 and 7.
Listen to this he says for to us a child
is born to us a son is given.
And the government shall be upon his shoulder and
his name Shall be Called wonderful counselor, Mighty
God Everlasting father Prince
of Peace.
Of the increase of his government and of Peace
there shall be no end.
On the throne of David and over his kingdom to establish
it to uphold it with Justice with righteousness from
this time forth and forevermore. The Zeal
or power of the Lord of hosts will do this.
So this ruler it's talking about.
That both Isaiah said Micah said
this ruler will have an ever-increasing eternal
Kingdom.
That's full of justice and righteousness and
peace.
Why because he's the Prince of Peace?
If if the Prince of Peace is in charge of the Kingdom,
what do you think is going to be evident in the Kingdom?
Peace is going to rain.
He is the Prince of Peace. So he is going to bring peace
and be peace for us and man. We
look forward to that day. Don't we?
when we see Strife in Nations
she Strife politically in her own Nation.
We see divisions in our
own families.
We long for the Prince of Peace that
one day. There will be peace on Earth as there is in heaven
already when the Messiah returns when he
comes and fully and finally Reigns on
the earth. He will bring peace across the
board as he is this Messiah King.
And the reality is that as we live out these principles daily these
Kingdom ideas. We see peace show
up more in our lives.
But listen, here's the most important way.
For you and me to experience peace today.
Is that we have peace with God through Christ.
right now
not just Pete like well how good what good is
it?
If we have no war no family Strife no issues in
the world and yet we don't have peace with God what good is that all?
Romans 5:1 says if we have been justified by
faith, we have peace with God through our
Lord Jesus Christ.
Remember what the angel said when they announced the birth
of Jesus to the Shepherds?
They appeared in the sky scared these guys to death, but they they
said something to them. They said glory to God in
the highest and on Earth peace among those
with whom he's pleased.
The Prince of Peace is coming.
Being born in Bethlehem. So come see
Glory to God in the highest but think about that if if
he came to bring peace and his his heart is to
create peace with God through Jesus Christ, if if
that's the truth and we would only
need to find peace with
God if we were at once at war with God,
right?
It you can't fix a problem. That's not
there. You can't bring peace to something if there's not enmity if
there's Not War.
If there's not Division, and so if we need peace with
God then we were at one time and are
in some cases at war with
God.
We're enemies in our sin.
with God
But that's what makes the good news truly good, right?
It's like Ephesians Romans 5:10 says while we were enemies. We
were reconciled to God by the death of his son.
Like we didn't even deserve this.
He looked across that battle line. So to speak
right you have that line between two warring armies.
He looked across there and he said no
you're coming with me.
You're my enemy and yet I love you enough to
pluck you out and pull you to my side
while we were enemies. We were reconciled to God by the death
of his son. That only happens through faith. It doesn't mean he just randomly chooses
people and you have nothing in part of
that like he says by faith.
Which means you're going to acknowledge that you're going to know that
he's calling you you're going to respond to his life death and
Resurrection in your place. You're gonna say Jesus you're Perfection counts
for mine your death counts for mine your Resurrection
counts for mine. That's what brings peace
with God Church.
Because the one who knew no sin.
Became sin on your behalf.
So that you might in him become the righteousness of God.
To give us peace with God to reconcile us
back to God. That's the gospel.
That's the hope we have the power of God for the
Salvation those who believe.
For those who place their faith in that Messiah.
The deliverer we've been promised.
Because here's what Romans 5:11 says that should lead
us to it says it should lead us to rejoicing.
Should lead us that we rejoice in God through
our Lord Jesus Christ through whom we've received reconciliation.
I mean just think.
About to know to know that you as an
enemy of God.
Due to your sin have now been reconciled back
to him through the Messiah. What
joy that brings right?
That your eternity is secure in
him.
Not because you have a hold on him. It's because he's
holding on to you. He's done it all he's accomplished the
task. He's paid the price. That's the hope and joy
we get that's what Israel was longing for.
When Micah preaches this message to them.
They're like give me some of that.
I want that whoever that guy is that Messiah Bring
It On.
I want that.
They were Longing For What Isaiah? 7:14 said would
come with the Messiah they longed for therefore.
The Lord himself will give you a sign the Virgin
shall conceive and bear a son and shall call
his name Emmanuel.
That word Emmanuel or Emanuel whichever way
you want to spell that. It means god with us.
It means god with us. They were longing for
the restoration of their land for them to be a nation
again with God as their King that he would come back
and Reign again, like he should then in a sense. We're still
waiting as well. Right? We're waiting for Emmanuel God In
the Flesh to come back and return and Reign fully
on Earth this Messiah to come back once and
for all we're longing for that as well.
But here's the difference.
We have something they didn't have.
What They Knew by faith we know by name
And that name is Jesus that name is this promised
messiah's name is Jesus Christ,
Jesus Messiah. He's the the John
1 Word become flesh who came and
dwelt among us. We've seen his glory glory is
the only son from the only father. That's what we have seen and
know and yeah, we're in Lexile right now. He's left us
for a little while and we struggle through that,
but we don't wait without hope
We don't wait without these glimmers of Light breaking
through the darkness.
That we see and know.
That because one thing he did.
while he was on Earth
paid the full penalty for our sin.
He made a way for us to be redeemed and reconciled back
to God. That's the one thing we know that they didn't know was coming.
We look back and we see that we are secure
forever in that Messiah.
That is why we can say that every day is Christmas Day.
because when this Messiah came
Not just we hope he does come someday when he came.
He fully did everything
needed.
To reconcile us back to God.
And one day he's coming back.
To set up his kingdom fully and finally hear on
Earth. And so when we look at all of that picture about who
this Messiah is, what should we do? We should rejoice
Christmas is every day of Our Lives because
that that Messiah has come.
And we rejoice.
If by faith your name is written in the Lamb's Book of Life
in heaven rejoice.
and rejoice
that your Messiah King is going to come back
one day and take you home with him.